[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con hoy
hablaremos sobre la advertencia que
hacen las autoridades sanitarias de
áfrica sobre una posible guerra por las
vacunas entre los países del continente
mientras se demoran los envíos de las
dosis en el siguiente mapa podemos ver
como los países desarrollados la mayoría
de ellos en la zona norte del mundo ya
han comenzado activamente sus campañas
de vacunación mientras que gran parte de
áfrica apenas está recibiendo las dosis
en el continente sólo marruecos ha
inmunizado ya a más del 3 por ciento de
su población para hablar de este tema
nos acompaña a francisco pavao médico
experto en salud pública y global además
a ser parte del equipo médico de un
hospital en luanda en angola gracias por
estar aquí doctor con nosotros en france
24 usted que ha trabajado en la primera
línea para combatir esta pandemia cómo
se vive la escasez de la vacuna y que
cree que podía generar la guerra por
este fármaco
buenos días me escucha sí sí
la me preguntabas que la demanda se está
generalizada por todo el mundo como los
sabios porque la vecina es los países no
saben que es un bien precioso y que
ayuda a ayuda a contener toda lavandería
disminuido los casos graves y las
muertes y por eso es un bien procurado
ahora por todos los países y los
gobiernos lo que ha dicho lo lo director
general de sds áfrica es que es una
guerra diplomática por las vacunas
porque se lo procesó de kóvacs de la de
la iniciativa kóvacs y está
por la disminución de producción india y
también por la parte legal y por otro
por la demanda de procura que se está
haciendo en india por esta vacuna y eso
hace con que los gobiernos se queden más
nerviosos y lo procuren con acuerdos
bilaterales o con otros mecanismos de
mercados
ahora doctor está preparado el
continente para una gran campaña de
vacunación que le permita alcanzar la
inmunidad de rebaño este mismo año 2021
bueno
la áfrica tiene 1.3 mil millones de
habitantes y se espera vacunar 60% de
sus habitantes al final de 2022 la
estimativa de la inicitiva kóvacs nos
dice que
podremos fascinar 20 por ciento de toda
la población africana al final de 2021 y
así solo vamos a dirigir o lograr una
inmunidad de grupo al final o medio de
ahora el serum institute de la india
produce las vacunas de astrazéneca que
se envían a áfrica a través de la
iniciativa internacional kóvacs para
garantizar la inmunización en países de
bajos y medianos ingresos hasta ahora al
menos 28 de los 54 países de áfrica han
recibido más de 16 millones de dosis a
través de kóvacs es esto suficiente
doctor
no es suficiente pero es un gran
esfuerzo global y sobre todo un gran
acto de solidaridad y de cooperación a
nivel mundial no nos podemos olvidar de
el lema de la oem y es que nadie está a
salvo hasta que todos estén a salvo esto
quiere decir que repara al 24 de febrero
del mes pasado
ghana ha recibido más de 600.000 dosis
de la vacuna y seguidamente en pocos
días la cote uag ha recibido también un
medio millón de vacunas angola ha
recibido a 2 de marzo 600.000 vecinas y
ayer
la china ha propuesto una 200.000 dosis
para angola por ejemplo y esto que dice
que no es no no es lo suficiente pero
hay un esfuerzo global muy grande para
que todas las poblaciones tengan acceso
a una vacuna
doctor y esperemos que así sea y se
pueda lograr entonces la inmunización
grupal en áfrica este mismo año gracias
por estar aquí con nosotros en france 24
estábamos conversando con el doctor
francisco para vado médico experto en
salud pública y global además hace parte
del equipo médico de un hospital en
luanda en angola para ver precisamente
toda esta proceso de inmunización en el
continente africano hasta aquí cinco
minutos con continúen con nosotros hasta
pronto